[Musique]
retour à montargis où pauline va mettre
en pratique ce qu'elle vient d'apprendre
du coup je sors de la production de la
praline et maintenant je vais aller très
rapidement à la l'école lui pralinette
depuis quelques mois une nouvelle
pâtisserie a vu le jour
on y vend des desserts à base de praliné
mais on y donne surtout des cours de
pâtisserie chef bonjour enchanté de même
bienvenu à la factory
au menu aujourd'hui donc la map à tisser
une tarte au chocolat exactement une
tarte au chocolat et aux pralines
évidemment bien ordinaire du praliné là
je vais prendre mon tablier pour pouvoir
aller pas tisser la trame au
commencement il y a le praliné une base
en pâtisserie prenait des noisettes ou
des amendes et ajouter de l'eau et du
sucre
on sait tout y'a vraiment pas besoin de
ça du gradient c'est maintenant fait
monter la température à 120 degrés pour
faire caraméliser le tout très bien donc
maintenant eh ben on va laisser
refroidir et on va s'attaquer à la pâte
tout à fait prêt la tarte sucrée est un
des fondamentaux à maîtriser pour
l'examen du cep de pâtisseries bon
maintenant ça rigole plus parce que la
tarte au chocolat elle peut tomber au ca
p donc il faut pas cacher mon groupe
pour réaliser cette pâte à tarte il faut
de la farine de la poudre d'amandes du
sucre glace 1 9 et du beurre pour
pauline c'est un test en conditions
presque réel en premier lieu envers
c'est donc la farine sur lequel
travaillent directement du coup dans
combien de temps est-ce que vous passez
un peu pataud
c'est début juin donc la préparation
elle commence à être un trou et pauline
et encore des choses à apprendre ou les
on va pouvoir pour gagner du temps
aujourd'hui c'est ap je vous déconseille
de faire une boule le temps de
refroidissement à coeur sera doublée
voire triplée
d'accord il faut l'étalé ok on veille
toujours à ce que notre tarte puissent
bien se déplacer parfait ok ils
attendront le parfait une fois la pâte
cuite
il faut terminer le praliné préparer la
ganache au chocolat et dressé après un
peu de repos
le chef peut rendre son verdict voilà
les fondamentaux sont là bon travail on
va déguster avec plaisir aurait rejet
complet sur le couteau retirer le
couteau sera plus voilà on voit bien là
la couche aussi en dessous traminer way
second fou peut-être secondes donc voilà
où nous n'avons sûr avec le praliné
s'achève ici j'ai terminé ma part je
suis contente j'ai appris plein de
choses pour mon service ça va vraiment
mettre utile
maintenant je vais continuer ma route et
je vais aller découvrir votre spécialité
de la région centre val de loire
une prochaine fois